[Applause]
away
yes I missed the hang glider oh
yeah I hate myself too we'll take five
random topics then we'll drop a beat and
do a pretty swish freestyle let's let's
divide you guys uh did you just put a
hand up there so I hadn't even come to
your section yet but but sure go ahead
the Trail of Tears the Trail of Tears
now so red do you not know that
the Trail of Tears so I believe that was
Andrew Jackson's policy to to March the
Native Americans from their reservations
to new reservations and on the way they
died as a byproduct but actually as the
purpose of the Trail of Tears so yeah
um look I am as amazed that I knew that
as you are I don't know where that came
from because yeah that's not taught in
England really in England we you know we
reached you know 1776 and then we
stopped learning about your country
because
it became your country we're like oh
[__] them then whatever
when we had it we cared so the Trail of
Tears so I guess when when was this was
this in the kind of 1800s
1820s cool thank you so much and thank
you for really setting it off it was a
great mood isn't it that's what you want
in the evening on a Saturday a free star
up at the Trail of Tears well there's
four more suggestions to fill it in so I
mean we didn't even get a suggestion
from you lovely people over here what
would you like a rap about
drugs do you just say drugs
a topic rarely broached in rap music
oh if only if only they would rap about
that um do you have a particular type of
drug that you're a fan of
um okay you had no preference but Zoloft
yes that's a that's an antidepressant I
would assume cool it's a good name
actually isn't it that's whoever came up
with that in branding they knocked out
of the park Zoloft are you a user of
Zoloft
from New York
gosh what a depressing statement in
itself which suggests that Zoloft is not
working
the person who went whoa it's definitely
working keep at it
the Trail of Tears and drugs
specifically Zoloft don't worry I
remembered
one of the side effects of Zoloft is
very short-term memory loss
people over here what would you like a
rap about
[Applause]
let me back okay so um May I um you you
look like a reasonably active man what
was the last kind of outdoor activity
you engaged in
[Music]
you can just lie if there wasn't one I
don't mind
he was just like no Chris you're really
trying to make me look I was just you
know you have a tattoo on your forearm
so I was like oh he climbs
no you read comic books that what that
means
you took the subway that's not an app is
that
assume like mountain biking or bold ring
but I took the subway Chris that's an
extreme sport it really is
your accent's delectable where's it from
Israel is beautiful it sounds lovely can
you can you say I took the subway in
your voice that's what everyone to hit
it's like it's like caramel in ears
I mean that was that was in in in Hebrew
as well right [__] two of my um
tumescent right now
um sorry that means hard uh okay
sorry I forgot we're not back in England
so okay Jeffrey Epstein taking the
subway that's the the topic there this
corner and what was like a rap about
implants uh may I inquire as to what
location on the body we're going Dental
are we going derriere are we going
butt implants okay thank you very much
you see seated comfortably over there
you're having a good yes and then one
final one because so far these are
pretty good we're gonna top it off with
the creme de La Creme which is French
for creamiest cream
what what did you say in the middle
you started something here that's not me
suggesting you start today that was me
saying that it's a you're too young
um
tell you what seeing as we've got
already the Trail of Tears it's it
probably would be a little too a little
too sad
um I mean we've got Zoloft actually
it'll make it work but
there was there was a feminine voice
that didn't say AIDS what did you say
[Music]
Cubans going to Miami in a hang glider I
apologize for saying your voice was
feminine
Cuban's going to Miami in a hang glider
great the suggestions to remind you the
Trail of Tears [__] you uh drugs
specifically Zoloft Jeffrey Epstein
taking the subway but buttock implants
and Cubans going to Miami in a hang
glider
that actually makes more sense than it
did when you said it yes I realize
there's there's embargoes and borders
and so why not you know deliver cocaine
in a functional way
um Miami has lots of cocaine importing
doesn't it
um thank you but has great health care
good for them let's let's do this let's
make up a wrap for my my lovely friends
in the audience yeah you gave good
suggestions we'll do our best to make a
good wrap let's hear what my band have
got to serve up
[Music]
it's not the beat I was expecting at
this time of night but
yeah it makes it kind of romantic really
I'm quite glad we rejected AIDS as a
suggestion given the the sultry
luxurious Vibes that Red's thrown up
well let's um
let's do this we're taking off like a
Runway seeing that pedophile dead on the
subway did he kill himself hanging from
the straps Jeffrey Epstein we could
throw him back she's laying Maxwell
she's like you should take the a or the
F that's the orange line no way he would
use an Ube or a private jet the Lolita
Express that's the plane that he'd get
the underage ladies on he doesn't like
it mass transit usually you can't find a
place to sit he's like nobody likes me
unless they're a politician then they
invite me to sit by them friends in high
places we're coming over here the smiles
on your faces but maybe when the drugs
wear off you pop a pill again yes thanks
Zoloft that's the drug that we need get
in your brain serotonin generators
cocaine is a basic one but this makes me
smile properly you were like New York
City of course I need a prescription it
comes with the rent your girl was like
whoa it doesn't make sense Zoloft Zoloft
Zoloft for me Zoloft it sounds like
actually Ahmad dude over here we need
you you were saying right in on the
subway in Hebrew sounding so sexy even
though I am a male I would have sex with
you your voice from Israel sounds
incredible you're off that proclivity
Subway that's an outdoor activity it
didn't really fit but you took your
chance I'll take a glance here nice butt
implants I really like it looking over
there extra cushion on the chair in your
Derry yeah where did you go to get these
feel in the thrill fill up my backside
down in Brazil it's where it was started
can't resist those big hits with the
Butt Lift you're going to the surgeon
it's actually a problem because the
chance of dying when you've got them is
really quite High I'm just saying dying
for beauty that's what we're praying
also you could just work out a lot go to
the gym do the one-legged squats do the
leg push but that doesn't take us quick
time okay over here yeah this brick my
guy in the row he was like you'll fear
any suggestion but especially the Trail
of Tears oh yeah suggestion it's a whack
one who's responsible for it Andrew
Jackson the worst president a real
[__] Champ but really in the overlap
is right behind Trump he had a picture
of him that's a [__] weird icon oh
the Native Americans they were on their
land literally they owned it but
Jackson's like now you've got to go it
goes south go west walk with no food
again see how this really killed the
mood just talking about the Indians they
were dismayed and imagine how it'd kill
it if you said Aid so I'm glad you
didn't I'm glad you wouldn't we're gonna
have fun yeah we know we're pushing did
we do all of the five is there no more
to do well there we go the Freestyle
right we run the course through boom
oh
dubins going to Miami in a hang glider
oh [__] ah yeah I hate myself too okay
make it a little bit faster then because
uh okay cool we make it faster the BPM
cracks up we move there grooving I'm
taking hang gliders from Cuba I'm using
the power there at the Zephyr Miami the
Florida they would never guess a Cuban
guy coming over here me oh my my plan I
mix it with ham there in the sky because
they've got the ham and pork that's a
Cuban sandwich I know you're Jewish so
you wouldn't manage with that that's
okay a forbidden meat the Cuban guy
coming soaring many feet above the
ground he comes in and he lands though
about three hours drive south of Orlando
why is he doing escaping all the
Communist he was like Fidel Castro wall
he'd be pretty pissed that's the
dictator that he feared he doesn't like
the guy with all the cigars and the
Beards or maybe Che Guevara but now he
lands there he sees sexy ladies on the
stands there he says holy hell makes my
dick stand up they look nice because
they got the implants in their butts
there we go
thank you bye